[Music]
good afternoon everybody
you know we began the festival with a
celebration of the hundredth anniversary
of the confirmation of Einstein's
general theory of relativity which was
on the 29th May 29th and that moment in
the history of science is a pivotal one
a beautiful one because it really shows
the optimum way for signs to progress we
have a body of thinkers in this
particular case it was design Stein
himself but more generally it's a
community of theoreticians who use
mathematics to try to figure out some
deep insight about the nature of reality
but importantly that insight needs to
come with predictions and those
predictions then can inspire other
physicists other astronomers or
experimentalist to go out and try to
confirm the prediction and see whether
the mathematics is actually describing
true aspects of reality now for Einstein
it was a wonderful confluence of the
mathematics and the technology necessary
to check the mathematics because he
wrote down his equation of the general
theory of relativity in November of 1915
and the observations that confirmed his
ideas happened in 1919 so just four
years between the theory and the
observation oftentimes in physics the
timescales are longer the irritations
will come up with the ideas perhaps
they're difficult to test perhaps it
will take building new equipment
perhaps it will take in fact countries
to come together to put their resources
together to combine the resource in
order to even be able to build the
machines necessary to test these ideas
and that is going to be part of what
will drive our conversation here today
but whereas Einsteins ideas and his
confirmation was all about sort of
looking up into the sky
thinking about gravity thinking about
big things the focus here will be on the
other end of the spectrum for the most
part thinking about small things
particles because we have four you can
really trace the history back thousands
of years asked ourself the question what
is stuff made of what are the
fundamental ingredients and we have
thought about this over the course
really of many many centuries but that
program of trying to figure out the
basic ingredients of matter really
picked up in the middle of the 20th
century and it was a wonderful time
where the theorists and the
experimentalist really worked hand and
glove back and forth playing off of each
other and Steven Weinberg one of the
great scientists of our era summarized
the excitement in a really wonderful
ways it was a time when graduate
students would run through the halls of
a physics building say they discovered
another particle and it fit the theories
and it was also exciting back and forth
between the mathematical ideas that
inspired the experimentalist to look for
certain kinds of particles they find the
particles come back the theorists would
then update their equations with the new
insights and back and forth it went and
as this
unfolding occurred there was one
sticking point which is really going to
be part of the focus of our conversation
here today which is there was a very
basic question why is it that these
particles that were being found have
heft have mass in essence if you had one
of these particles fundamental particle
in front of you it could be an electron
it could be a cork whatever as you push
on it where does its resistance to your
push come from where does its hef where
does its mass originate and a
mathematical idea was put forward that
we will discuss in the 1960s by Peter
Higgs and other scientists as well and
it was a strange idea to solve this
conundrum because it required the
universe to be filled with something
that we physicists often referred to as
a cosmic molasses some stuff that would
be filling space
moreover it came with the prediction
that if you kind of banged on this
molasses sufficiently in the right way
you could sort of have a little Fleck
that would come off and that little
piece of the molasses would be a
particle called the Higgs particle or
the Higgs boson and on July 4th of 2012
if you weren't out celebrating and doing
whatever we Americans do on Independence
Day for actually paying attention to
something some of us consider to be much
more important you might have seen the
following press conference if we combine
the ZZ and gamma gamma this is what we
get they line up extremely well and in
the region of 125 GeV they combine to
give us a combined significance of five
standard deviations
[Applause]
[Music]
so the emotional gentlemen taking off
his glasses wiping his eyes you might
guess that was of course Peter Higgs the
gentleman whose mathematics was put
forward in the 1960s and about half a
century later was confirmed through the
observation of this Higgs particle and
of course this excited the world it was
picked up by newspapers television shows
around the world because this is again
one of those iconic moments in the
history of deep understanding but at the
same time the discovery of exactly what
we expected to find based upon the
mathematics raised a certain kind of
challenge which is what's next and
that's what we are going to have a
discussion about here today and we have
some of the world's leading thinkers on
these ideas of particle physics so let
me now bring them out to you our first
participant this afternoon as a theorist
at the Institute for Advanced Study a
member of the National Academy of
Sciences he was an inaugural recipient
of the breakthrough prize in fundamental
physics please welcome Nima Carney Hamed
[Applause]
also joining us is an experimental
high-energy particle physicist working
on the Atlas detector at the Large
Hadron Collider at CERN
please welcome Monika Dunford all right
finally please join me in welcoming the
deputy director of research at the Fermi
National Accelerator Laboratory he's a
fellow of the American Physical Society
and the American Association for the
Advancement of science please welcome
Joel Icahn I've known all you guys for
many years probably known Joe the
longest of all I think we probably go
back 30 years but whoever wrote my
little notes here probably didn't know
that fact because they have told me that
your name is pronounced lickin just like
finger-licking good so so let's begin
the discussion by just going way back
for a moment way back to you know
ancient Greece when there were thinkers
who began to ask the question you know
what is matter made of what is the stuff
around the world made of and so we have
this this fellow right here sanema who
is this end and what role did he play in
your mind this is mister Democritus
apparently I don't know how we made it
look like that but anyway but now
Democritus is widely credited as being
the person who suggested that the world
is actually made up out of atoms that
matter is made out of some fundamentally
smallest building blocks and just tell
us your view of that I think he's a
single most over credited individual in
human history because there's absolutely
no evidence one way or the other whether
this idea was right you know you're just
sitting around in ancient Greece hey you
think matter you know you keep cutting
it up it goes all the way down forever I
don't know yeah I do know I don't and
you know there's absolutely no reason to
believe either one either way the guy
who said that it stops somewhere I he's
famous for 2500 years let me ask you one
thing though so we certainly tell our
students and I think it's a real truism
that asking the question is often
oh yeah as important as finding the
answer so perhaps maybe it's worth
crediting him with at least thinking
about the possibility that this is a
worthwhile the question to investigate
what you said it's true but I'm not
historian of science I don't so so the
idea that that he had of course was
presumably you take a piece of matter
and you start to sort of pound on it or
cut it up in some we have an example
here is Iraq and so what have we found
in the past you know 2,000 years if we
easily start the journey with Democritus
yeah so I think a little over a hundred
years ago I mean in the mid-1800s
I guess chemists or back in the time
when there was not such a distinction
between the different physical sciences
but anyway people started suspecting
that there might be atoms that
ultimately different kinds of material
were made out of different sort of
building blocks we have the system of
the periodic table of elements and so on
and already back then there are people
who are skeptical that you were talking
about these teeny teeny tiny things that
no one can actually see but they're
started to be more and more in direct
evidence that atoms actually exist of
course today we see them in various ways
directly but that's where the sort of
journey began that you know big hunks of
matter are made out of molecules or in
turn collections of atoms and atoms
maybe you know a a 100 millionth of a
centimeter across so it's a very it's
it's it's very very very small but then
the atoms themselves were built out of
other constituents we have the electrons
we all heard about in school that were
around the nucleus of the atom the
nucleus of the atom in turn is around a
million times smaller than the size of
the atom itself so these kind of
pictures are not really to scale right
the nucleus is around a million times
smaller than the atom itself then we go
into the nucleus we see that the nucleus
is made out of particles like protons
and neutrons which are now around 10 to
the minus 14 centimeters big and around
56 years ago we started peering inside
gradually these apparently elementary
objects protons and neutrons that turned
out not to be elementary at all
and built out of still more point-like
constituents so that's that's where the
journey has been taking us young in this
at least in this building blocks of
matter perspective on what it is that we
do and hopefully we'll come back and
talk about some other perspectives on
what it is that we actually do but
anyway in this in this very fundamental
aspect of what we do that's that's the
journey that we've been on we're now at
a distance around what we're probing at
the largest experiments in the world
like the large the largest
accelerators in the world like the Large
Hadron Collider are distances around a
thousand times smaller than that a
thousand times smaller than the nucleus
of the atom and there's a lot of drama
that has unfolded there and so Monica
you know when we show a picture as we
began there with whatever a sledgehammer
smashing into rock it suggests the most
brutish way of figuring out what's
inside of Maddie just sort of smash it
apart and see what the constituents it's
like a five-year-old just smashing
things together to see what's in there
is that what we do at the Large Hadron
Collider or would a more refined way be
to make you say of equals mc-squared
sort of the most famous of all formula
so you know are we using energy to
create stuff or we just sort of smashing
things to bids I think pretty much it's
one of the same I think it's just a
question of whether or not you want to
speak elegantly or or not so yes I mean
in essence what we do is we take two
things and we smash them together and
what we want out of that of course
there's a lot of energy right and at any
collision you want a lot of energy and
as Einstein says energy is equal to
matter and so therefore we can produce
heavy things and that's our goal but but
a key part of them the point which I
probably didn't say clearly was if you
only are smashing things you're only
gonna find the stuff that was literally
there whereas that's not quite what we
don't exactly know that is absolutely
not what we do it's sort of like it
would be more as if you took two let's
say cheap cars and you smash and you got
yourself a Ferrari right that would be
more the equivalent of what we're doing
I mean it's you're really creating
something new out of what you had and
what you had is is now no longer and
you've got this
you know elegant it's hard to find
status symbol that you're really looking
for so that that is more along the lines
of what we do so so from that way of
looking at things energy is sort of the
the basic currency from which you can
buy the status symbol energy is money in
our case right so the more energy you
have the more options you have for the
things that you can buy or we get off
this metaphor which perhaps is a good
idea the greater the mass of the
particles that you're able to create
through these collisions so the idea
behind any sort of what we would call
frontier Collider is that it needs to be
as energetic as you can as you can by
really literally give me we want a big
you want it powerful you want tons of
particles you want tons of energy you
just you want it all so what's our the
most powerful Collider of that sort that
we have today I gather is very large
work so and and so give us some sense of
what it can do and the energy that it
has and so on so the Large Hadron
Collider yeah it's in a tunnel it's
about 27 kilometers located near Geneva
Switzerland and probably some of the
most expensive real estate in the world
so probably in future colliders Wow you
wouldn't have designs what's it in
Switzerland now let's say but it's where
we have it and the idea is you've got
two protons that are running around in
this ring in opposite direction they're
being celebrated by superconducting
magnets they are you know getting to
very very high energies energy is
currency here so the higher the better
this one runs about 13 TV soon to be 14
and then you collide them together you
have a tremendous amount of energy in
that collision and you basically build
this gigantic detector we have four two
such detectors you build these gigantic
detectors around that collision point
you know the Atlas detector which is a
sector that I work on is a five-story
building so it's humongous and that
basically takes a snapshot of the
collision and the collision is messy
it's not like you know a couple of
particles here or there right I mean
it's how many protons are in these these
bunches that are slams I mean the
protons you have you have many many
protons in
a bunch so the button the beam is it's
not a continuous beam as you might think
it's not like a stream of protons that
are coming in the beam is designed such
that you have like little packets of
protons you know well 10 to the 11
around and you have these little packets
of protons and they're kind of colliding
every 25 nanoseconds which means that
it's like your camera your detectors a
camera and it's taking pictures every 25
nanoseconds so 40 megahertz speed and
these collisions are so big and are
happening so often that we actually
cannot record all of the data and we
have to make a very difficult decision
quickly within a microsecond about
whether or not this event is interesting
or not and this is a very challenging
thing for us experimentally because if
you know NEMA comes to me a year from
now and he says oh you know what I think
I saw a new signature would be something
totally different and it would have
looked like this and if my trigger
system that system that makes that
decision wasn't looking for that yeah or
couldn't the data's lost I didn't record
it so I can't go back to the data and
say oh I can look for that so theory
really guides the experimental approach
it's not as though you approach it as a
blank slate and say let's slam these
things together and just see what
happens well it's it's absolutely and
it's also a very difficult challenge
experimentally because in one hand you
need to be ready for everything your
detector cannot record everything so you
can't take everything so you want to be
ready for everything however you need to
have made a decision so you need to sort
of have some sort of idea about what
you're looking for and to get that idea
of what we're looking for then yes of
course we rely heavily on theory and
tell us that because otherwise done you
know you're at sea we're at sea you're
absolutely at sea so Joe you of course
also have spent your career working at a
facility that undertakes these kinds of
experiments as well Fermilab and over
the course of decades both through
Collider experiments but also through
other kinds of experiments that we won't
go into any detail in cosmic ray
experiments and other things of that
sort we have built up what we think may
be
the fundamental ingredients making a at
least the stuff that we interact with in
an everyday sense and that's the
standard model of particle physics so I
just wanted to go through the particles
that were predicted and ultimately found
giving us our most complete
understanding to date of what things are
made of so it's in the early days of
looking for particles maybe just sort of
take us through sure some of these
particles here so that's that's a
familiar one electrons everybody those
electrons everybody knows photons the
muon was an example of a particle that
wasn't predicted but was discovered and
we still don't know why they exist but
they are also fundamental particles
similar to electrons neutrinos even
stranger there we know they exist but
they're they're very different from the
particles that you're made out of but
that's one of the things we're still
trying to figure out and they what they
have no electric they don't have any
electric charge they're very difficult
to detect and and they're very very
different from from other particles
quarks american murray gell-mann who
just recently passed away invented the
the idea of quarks you are made out of
actually only three of these particles
the electron and two of those quarks the
up and down U and D courts that's what
all of leave that's what all of you are
made out of it but there are more quarks
there's the strange quark you see there
was discovered later and charm quarks
bottom quarks top quarks were discovered
at my laboratory Fermilab we're very
proud of them and what year was that
that was in 1997 with the what was then
the world's biggest particle collider
the the Tevatron before the LHC and we
don't know why there are so many of
these elementary particles as you
there's way more than you need to make
us so that's one of the things that's
still a big mystery and we don't know
why they're so different from each other
we have some ideas for that but it's
it's part of the the big mystery of this
whole picture of the standard model is
is why is it so complicated in some
sense and also why is it so simple there
are simple principles that hold it
together so so we see here two
collections of particles if you will the
ones on the green you know in the far
right hand sides are
distinct you know in a fundamental way
from those on the left-hand side you
just draw that this thing yeah so the
particles that you are made out of are
called fermions since when we talk about
matter particles matter particles are
fermions and and they're one of the ways
of distinguishing them is that they they
carry a little unit of spin which is not
really spinning around like balls cuz
they're point-like particles but they
carry a little bit of spin like angular
momentum so you're made out of fermions
on the other hand the forces that hold
you together and hold the universe
together are carried by these bosons
these green particles of which the
photon is the most obvious example for
electromagnetism but the gluon and the w
and z also carry fundamental forces of
nature and those are particles that have
a different spin they have spin that's
actually twice that the unit of what
fermions heaven they're called bosons
and they behave very differently they
behave like forces instead of behaving
like matter now nema so when we actually
begin to look at the mathematics behind
this one of the curious features that
people recognize even before the theory
was fully in place was that it was
challenging to give mass to these
particles and it's challenging to
describe why it was difficult to give
mass to these particles I'm gonna ask
you to try to do it oh okay yeah good
it's actually it's actually it's
actually a piece of cake
in fact what what we're about to talk
about is a very large part of the
conceptual drama of the 20th century in
fundamental physics and we're just gonna
have to count on our fingers a a little
bit so um maybe before getting to it I
just want to make one just general
comment about this this picture is that
you might um and it's echoing something
that it's been said a couple of times
already on the one hand it looks a
little bit complicated it's not the most
complicated thing you could imagine but
there's there's many particles and it
seems a little haphazard and random
perhaps but one of the aspects of our of
our subject think that the the deepest
aspect of our of our subject is that all
of these things are somehow completely
governed and there are their properties
the broad properties are almost entirely
dictated by big general principles these
these two revolution
principles in the earlier that we
learned in the early part of the 20th
century of the laws of relativity and of
quantum mechanics it turns out that
these laws are almost incompatible with
each other there's not at all remotely
obvious that you could come up even with
you know toy universes that were
compatible the principles of relativity
and of quantum mechanics but you just
barely can and if you a hand
sufficiently competent theoretical
physicists these laws and lock them up
in a room and refused to let them look
outside and just say what could you come
up with that's conceivably consistent
with these principles then this is the
kind of thing that that comes out in a
sense out of pure thought once you put
in of course these two big facts that
we've observed experimentally that
relativity and quantum mechanics are
both true and a very big aspect of this
and a very big reason why it's so
constrained is exactly this business
about the difference between being
massive and being massless so let me try
to describe this we just talked about
the photon and as Joe mentioned one of
the properties of the photon has is it
has a little spin if you're familiar
from just thinking about light as a wave
sort of classically is an
electromagnetic wave sometimes we talk
about it having polarization okay it can
spin around one way it could spin around
the other way well what's really going
on the underlying photons that make up a
light to have a little spin so they can
spin either in the directions they're
moving or opposite to the direction
they're moving and this is a crucial
fact that they can spin in two
directions now
the other particles like the W and Z
particles there are sort of massive
cousins of the photon but the mass is
not a tiny correction you see if you're
very naive you would think especially
when we go to these huge accelerators we
smash particles into each other at
incredibly high energies surely when the
energies are enormous you can kind of
ignore their mass so that the e is so
much bigger than the M so that you could
really just basically ignore the mass
and you can and get incredibly high
energies you can think of the masses a
little tiny perturbation and just talk
about massless particles but it's not
true it's not true because massive
particles that have spin one that that
I've spin twice to spend of the electron
we say it's spin one like the W Mzee
they have three ways that they can spin
while the photon has to and what's this
difference between this 3 and this 2
it's no matter how quickly this W
particle let's say is moving around you
can always catch up with it you can
always move and catch up with it let's
say it was spinning up this way well by
tilting your head you could see it
spinning that way or the other way as
well catch up with it because massive
exactly exactly that's right that's the
crucial point because it's massive no
matter how quickly it's moving it's not
moving at the speed of light and so you
can catch up with it whereas the
massless particle like the photon is
moving zipping around at the speed of
light you cannot catch up with it and
therefore you can't play this game where
you tilt your head and see it the spin
in every possible in all of the three
possible directions in fact all you can
do is conclude that it's either spinning
in the direction that it's moving in or
opposite to the direction that it's
moving in this to not equal to three
business is really profound it means
that you can't think of mass as just a
little correction the things that are
massless already and in fact precisely
because of this point if you attempt to
describe the the possible composition
types and interactions of massless
particles then it's essentially a
mathematical theorem it follows from the
again the following from the general
physical facts about the presence of
both relativity and quantum mechanics
but the types and interactions of
massless particles that you're allowed
to have have to come in a minuscule
variety okay so the menu of particles
that you're allowed to have that can
interact in a way compatible with the
principles of relativity and quantum
mechanics are the following the
particles can have spin zero one-half
that's the unit that the electron has
it's just a convention so one
three-halves and two that's it
that's all you can have furthermore
there can only be one of those massless
spin-2 particles so we're not going to
talk about it much today but you can
only have one of them and if you study
its properties that are sort of forced
on you by relativity in quantum
mechanics you would find that it makes
massive particles go around in orbits
and so on it's gravity okay and then all
the properties are sort of dictated by
these basic principles of Einstein's
special theory of relativity and of
quantum mechanics then the spin zero
particles okay you can have as many of
them as you like to spend a half you can
have as many as you like the massless
spin-1 particles have two very special
properties and interact with each other
in very special ways you can have
massive spend three have particles they
have to be even more special we might
come to that later and as I said the
massless spin-2 are are associated with
gravity so that's it there's a sort of
tiny menu of possibilities that you're
allowed to have and nature is making use
of that menu as far as we can tell so
we've seen of the set of possibilities
before July 4th 2012 we had seen nature
make use of some of these possibilities
it had used particles of spin 1/2
particles of spin 1 and of course this
has been - associated with with the
gravity one of the most exciting and
important things about the Higgs is it's
the first example of an elementary
particle that has no spin at all that
we've that we've ever seen so that's
been added to the that's been added to
the to the mix but the reason why the
Higgs had to be there is that something
has to account for this - not equals to
3 business ok something has got to
explain where mass comes from not just
not merely to add this number of the
actual mass of the particle but to
account for this extra stuff this extra
spin ways that the the extra ways that
things can spin when you give spinning
particles a mass and that's the entire
story of the Higgs is to account for
that for the for the for the origin of
these extra degrees of freedom they did
quite a piece of cake yeah but it's all
just about counting it really is all
just about this - not equals 2 or 3
business so with that as it preamble to
the motivation that you had to have
something fundamentally new added to the
story Monica can you take us back to the
1960s when Peter Higgs and others who
shared the Nobel Prize with him as well
and glare and so on what was the
approach that Peter Higgs took to add
this crucial profound new ingredient
that would fix up the two not equal to
three puzzle that Nia articulated well
so Peter Higgs postulated the Higgs
particle and well I wasn't there in the
60s so I can't really tell you a whole
lot about exactly what was going on
when that was but it was it was a pretty
revolutionary idea you know it was we
were stuck in the sixties
this point where we needed to you know
you you you had suddenly in the sixties
this this huge explosion of particles
right suddenly I mean the 60s was this
period where it was like every week
essentially new particles were being we
were being discovered and not not maybe
elementary particles like quarks and and
you know muons but more like we were
seeing mesons which are combinations of
two quarks or hadrons which are
combinations of three and you know every
week and so suddenly our kind of picture
of what the world was went from very
small you know what what made us up to a
whole fleet of particles it didn't
really seem to fit into anything we
didn't really meet them what why why do
we have a while suddenly all of these
extra particles and certainly you know
how do they all fit together you know
what's the bigger picture and then also
as you said what gives them mass and so
Higgs was you know part of that which
was sort of to say well postulated that
there was the actual and what was unique
about his paper was that he postulated
that there was the actual Higgs particle
yeah
and that it could be something that we
could then discover and detect so tell
us about so the Higgs particles that
keep part story tell us also about the
higgs field which ultimately is a key
part of getting a sense of how particles
acquire mass in this dimension this
phrase cosmic molasses I think this is
good a way of picturing it as anything
else but it's really a daring idea right
you're saying that all of space all the
whole universe is filled with this
cosmic molasses whose effect is to give
the particles that were made out of
another particles mass so that's a
really daring idea and and in fact Higgs
original paper on this was rejected for
publication it was considered a little
bit a little scene right here again so
these are the dots here meant to be the
molasses that you're referring to and
then one of these particles is meant to
be masses like the photon I guess and
the bottom one is meant to be massive so
what's happening to the guy in the
bottom so if if you're an electron and
you're moving through the molasses you'd
like to move at the speed of light like
a photon and the only thing that stops
you is the fact that there is a Higgs
field everywhere and and you can't avoid
it on the other hand for the photon the
photon is not
interacting least directly with with the
Higgs field and so it does if through
the speed of light and that's the
difference between those particles so so
for this crazy sounding idea to be true
we'd have to accept that empty space is
not empty and it's not even a quantum
mechanical notion of fluctuating fields
that people may have heard of this is
just there's actually a something there
permeating all of space obviously it's
invisible because we don't see it's
tasteless right like when I move my hand
am i touching it in some sense you you
are interacting with it all the time
because part of the resistance I feel as
I try to move my hand would be the
electrons and the quarks in some sense
moving against this molasses so it's
it's a far-out idea he puts forward this
paper and it gets as you say rejected
yes now many of us if we have a paper
rejected we kind of back off this is not
what Higgs did right he actually went
around and lectured on this and crosslet
eyes and discussed this and ultimately
I'm you know I've said it before but
when I was a graduate student and first
learned about these ideas the class that
I took the professor taught it with such
certainty that I had no idea that the
Higgs was a hypothetical idea there was
a time in our community by probably the
mid 80s early 90s it was almost a
foregone conclusion that this crazy
mathematical idea from the 60s which had
now somehow permeated the consciousness
of particle theorists around the world
that it was it was right but still you
gotta you gotta try to confirm it so we
start to look for it through these kinds
of collisions so mark I guess you were
you were were you were there when this
was actually happening so what was it
like and what exactly were you looking
for in those collisions well in the
beginning it was very intense I mean at
first when we first turned on the
accelerator we weren't really thinking
about the Higgs right then we were
thinking about my god please let it work
you know I mean it was it was 15 years
to build this detector you're working on
collaborations that are you know 3,000
people the days leading up to the start
of the beam
no one was sleeping and so forth and so
I think in the beginning you were more
concerned with the technical challenge
and the Higgs was sort of a far-off
dream and we certainly at that time when
we first turned on the accelerator and
and also you know just collecting up the
data you know we you've got a brand new
detector it's five stories tall it
involves you know millions of
electronics channels that all need to be
understood and calibrated and so forth
and the Higgs I remember people always
to say what are you gonna discover the
Higgs
theorists you know like Nemo would tell
anyone when he gonna discover it and I
was like you know give me give me five
years you know I've got to discover I've
got to figure out this detector we've
got to collect enough data and I think
for us we were really amazed may be very
happy with ourselves at how fast the
discovery was made actually I mean we
were not no one was predicting that we
would have discovered the Higgs in 2012
particularly nice it did it was it was
it was very nice spot for us it's very
easy
well you say spot you mean it's mass
presumably it's mass and and therefore
because of its mass it has many it has
the maximal possible ways in which it
came decay the Higgs do you find it so
so you smash these protons together what
happens matches protons together you get
a lot of energy and in that energy you
produce your Ferrari which is your Higgs
yep the Higgs then decays it falls apart
it falls apart not exactly a Ferrari
yeah well the Higgs Higgs falls apart
and you know and it Hicks will fall
apart too it prefers to couple the mass
which means that it prefers to fall
apart to the heaviest things that can
that it can so depending on the Higgs
mass if the Higgs is extremely massive
then it will prefer to follow it apart
to two top quarks if it's at 125 which
is where it's at 125 times the mass of
the proton exactly 100 25 times the mass
of the proton then it falls apart then
it can fall apart and a whole bunch of
things which is in essence an
experimental dream right right because
it means that it can fall apart to Z
bosons and you can look for for the
decay of the two Z's it can fall apart
to two photons it can fall apart to two
W bosons and so you have a variety of
different ways
experimentally you can test and that for
us was really key because it allowed us
to be able to to say okay I looked in to
I looked at the decay of the Higgs to
two Z's I see exactly where it should be
I looked at the decay of Higgs to two WS
I see exactly where it should be because
from an experimental perspective we
don't actually measure the Higgs right
never measure the Higgs so all we knew
at that time was we had measured
something new whether or not it was the
actual Higgs boson we then had to
compare the rate of decay to two Z's the
rate of decay to two w's of which the
theory once you know it's mass is
predicted exactly so if you if there's
an announcement in like July 4th when
did you know that you had or when were
you fairly certain that you had it is it
is it months before is it six months
before the day before
I mean you I mean statistics is such
that you know we were collecting data
and and if you if you see some sort of
statistical signal you should expect
that it's more and more data you know
the size of the Signet of the size of
your you know Higgs peak let's say it
starts growing and growing and growing
yeah but that's not actually usually how
we ecstatic
we usually get it in chunks even though
the accelerator is kind of working
continuously over the day you know we
have to calibrate our detector and we we
tend to data just kind of comes to us in
chunks well do this calibration try to
understand it okay that's trunk' will do
this calibration and that's kind of
chunk B so we're kind of looking at it
kind of in chunks at a time and because
a false discovery is worse than death
let's let's put it that way death would
be better so a false discovery is yes
you're gonna do anything anything we we
oftentimes do is we blind the data from
ourselves right so we will we will do
the entire analysis chain where we have
and we can do blinding and a variety of
different what there's several
strategies but what means is either we
withhold from looking at a particular
data or we screw with the data such that
we can't actually get
the right answer and we so we make sure
that everything is correct our
calibrations our analysis selection so
forth and so on and then we unblind and
it's extremely stressful that moment
when you get the you get it's a
collaboration of 3,000 people and then
they agreed unblind
and you you know someone hits the you've
got a computer program someone starts it
you know you're watching the data being
processed watching it being process to
get the plots is it there is it not is
it there is it not I mean so it's in
that sense it was semi instantaneous and
and now that you have the Higgs and
we're gonna now turn to the question of
like going beyond this this major
discovery you or actually at the World
Science Festival about I think was 10 10
years ago having a conversation prior to
the discovery of the Higgs and I thought
I'd just show you a little little clip
from that if you don't mind so can you
just run that that little the worst
scenario as far as I'm concerned would
be that the LHC sort of completes the
standard model and and doesn't do
anything more so in the standard model
as it stands we need this cosmic
molasses that was mentioned we don't
know what it's made out of the simplest
idea is that it's made out of one new
particle is so-called Higgs particle and
that could be true and then you've
accounted for the missing ingredient of
the standard model and that would be it
and that would be horrifying Monica well
I think there's there's pretty much two
scenarios where I would end up at
McDonald's and that is that if we
discover the Higgs and Higgs only which
is Frank's worst case scenario and also
mine so far every Collider experiment we
have is really you know has predicted
this and we measure it its predicts
animal predicts this and we've measured
it animal and so success is our curse
yeah a success is our curse exactly and
and so I think from the experimental
perspective we're really sick of the
standard model
so just continue to measure the standard
model which would be a Higgs and Higgs
only scenario would be frustrating so so
you said there's a scenario you'd wind
up at McDonald's you're not at
McDonald's so I'm assuming that in the
second part of our discussion so let's
let's think about how we go beyond and
how we've tried to go beyond these ideas
and to sort of start that discussion
you know nimi you pointed out that the
standard model has a sensible simplicity
and complexity sort of depending on how
you look at it and we were looking at it
just graphically with the particles
arranged a nice little rows and columns
if you actually look at the equations
underlying the standard model of
particle physics you just like write
them all out this is what the equation
looks like which certainly has a sense
of complexity associated with it it's
sort of hard to imagine that you know
after you know certain number of days
and nights the Lord simply said let
there be the standard model Lagrangian
you know so now you can also tell me
this is misleading because this is the
most naive way of writing out the
equations and what we have found over
the course of many decades is that
symmetry is sort of an important way of
being able to repackage our
understanding in a way that really
simplifies and allows us to shine a
light going forward so Jo can you say a
little bit about symmetry sure and and
and and how for instance it helps us to
understand this better and illuminates
the path going forward yeah so it's
symmetry of course is something we're
familiar with in everyday life
snowflakes of interesting symmetries a
diamond is a good example of symmetry in
physics you know what's the difference
between a diamond and the graphite in
the pencil they're both made out of
carbon but the difference is that
diamond is in a beautiful crystal
lattice symmetry and that's what gives
diamonds its special properties and so
symmetry in in the physics world it it's
controls the physics properties of the
things that you're talking about
this happens in the subatomic world as
well and and and what we're talking
about symmetry in the standard model
we're actually talking about principles
that control how the standard model
works and actually make it much simpler
than it could otherwise have been and
that's why those complicated equations
can actually be expressed almost in
words in terms of a few symmetry
principles in fact you can even use that
simile chics
to put those equations on a coffee
exactly as has their job I think it's
worth it's worth really stressing that
these it's a kind of an unusual sort of
symmetry that we're talking there are
some important differences we don't have
time to really get into it but but this
very simplicity and the fact that
there's a certain kind of symmetry that
is useful for theorists to describe the
physics has everything to do with this -
not equal to three BS absolutely
everything to do with the fact that
we're only allowed this tiny menu of
elementary particles when they're
massless and that that mass is a big is
a big perturbation so yes
trying to describe massless particles
which we think we should be doing in
some approximation when we go to very
high energies that's what forces you to
do these incredibly simple compacts
looking formulas and these formulas are
really directly reflecting the
underlying principles of space-time and
quantum mechanics that govern everything
so so it's there's there's not very
there's no real veil between these these
remarkable simple formulas and these
grand underlying principles of 20th
century physics and to draw the
connection to two Higgs and others who
were working along the same lines in the
60s one way of describing what they
found was a powerful way of including
mass in a manner that didn't spoil the
beautiful underlying symmetry in fact I
would say that I mean that there isn't
this molasses analogy is it's probably
the sort of best the metaphorical
analogy that when when one can use it
raises various questions that probably
occur to you if you're a kid in the
audience you know is this like the ether
all over again
you know physicists don't learn anything
they're so dumb you know they didn't do
not have the ether yeah the ether
hundred years ago and it's gone now all
we can say is that this is something but
it's not like the ether it sounds like
either but it's not
like either and but I suspect the most
fundamental way of saying what the Higgs
is about the way that you know people
will still be talking about in two or
three hundred years after maybe robots
have come up with better metaphors and
analogies is that is sort of precisely
what what Brian just said the world of
massless particles is completely
prescribed and sort of fixed by general
principles of space-time and quantum
mechanics the world around us appears to
have massive particles in it and so you
have to somehow take the stuff that you
see that slow and massive and low
energies and as you collide them at
higher and higher energies be able to
continuously interpolate to a to a world
with massless elementary particles
smashing into each other at very high
energies and if you if you just finish
this counting that we talked about you
went through it a little bit more detail
you would find that there's you just
can't do it with the elementary
particles that we knew of before the
Higgs you just have to have something
else in order to be able to take massive
low-energy particles and interpolate
them to massless high-energy ones the
incredible thing and this is part of the
sort of cognitive dissonance and the
real irony about the Higgs you just
described it for example is something
people knew ought to be there for 50
years you know so that's like it's very
amazing that people predicted it but
it's sort of boring that it's the thing
that we expected all along but it's in
fact something it's actually quite
shocking well welcome to come to it
later in the discussion it's quite
shocking that all it took was one
stinking little elementary particle just
one extra thing was needed to allow us
to be able to interpolate smoothly and
continuously between this world of
massive particles at low energies and
this very sharply prescribed world of
massless particles at very high energies
and it's shocking that it was so simple
that's the that's the irony about the
Higgs that we all come to it is that
nowhere else in physics when this rough
type of phenomenon happened did anything
remotely as simple as the Higgs happen
and it's a it's a feature of the of an a
mysterious feature of our world that the
simplest possible answer ended up being
wrong so along those lines you know as
we've tried to push our understanding of
the world further using this idea of
symmetry particles that in some sense
are the different tips of the snowflake
to use Joe's metaphor that can kind of
be rotated into each
they're in some sort of abstract sense
we have come upon other symmetries
mostly from mathematical studies not
really from observations of the world
and the most prominent among those is
supersymmetry so can you tell us a bit
about supersymmetry and what it implies
for what we should find out there in the
real world if nature abides by this
particular symmetry so supersymmetry is
actually an idea that relates not the
tips of the snowflake but it actually
relates the kinds of particles that we
said we were made out of these fermions
of matter particles to the bosons like
the particles that carry forces so so
that's a found like a very profound
relationship and it is a very profound
relationship
it was first noticed by a bunch of
physicists in the 1970s and immediately
got the whole community that we belong
to excited because it sounds like it's a
it's a theoretical breakthrough it also
makes predictions it predicts a bunch of
new particles now the way you framed it
let me just say the way you framed it
was it takes the particles that make us
up and it relates us to the particles
say that and make up light like the
photon yeah that sounds very economical
yes it's it's not quite as economical as
you might have thought because for
example the electrons you have in your
body are related to a boson and
supersymmetry but it's not the photon
and it's not any of the other bosons you
showed on your chart it would be a new
particle we call it this electron in
fact I think you see it up that hasn't
been discovered yet yeah so it's in that
sense it doesn't sound economical
because it's postulating a whole bunch
of new particles that nobody had seen on
the other hand there's historical
analogy for why this might be reasonable
which goes back to what Nima was talking
about was the early days of quantum
mechanics when we're trying to
understand how quantum mechanics can be
made compatible with relativity and as
Nima said that that is a very very
difficult mathematical understanding
which was part of it was first put
together by Paul Dirac one of the great
Giants of our field and he found in
making that work it just in the
mathematical basis that that predicted
also a bunch of new particles what we
now call antimatter anti particles which
also seems pretty out there
and in fact direct it took him a long
time to convince himself that this Eve
was reasonable but he was right and in
fact he was super lucky because the
first antiparticles discovered about a
year after his his prediction came out
we now know that antiparticles exists we
can make them and they're part of our
standard model
so in some sense supersymmetry is if you
like the next phase of that it's saying
yes there's anti particles and then
there should also be these superpartner
particles and you just have to go out
and find them so so well so let me just
make sure we have the full playing field
so the idea then is we see a pattern
playing itself out over the course of
the last 100 if not more years where you
invoke some notion of symmetry embodied
in mathematics and make some statement
about the world you resisted at first
because it's something I haven't yet
seen but then you go out and you look
for it and you happen to find it in fact
there's a beautiful quote I think it's
Steven Weinberg where he said the
problem with steers is that not that we
don't take our equations seriously
enough is that it's not that we take
them too seriously that we don't take
them seriously enough yeah good we have
it right here and and and so if you sort
of take this to heart it does suggest
that if there's just beautiful new
symmetry then as you say seems to in
some sense be the final symmetry that
you could ever invoke because it puts
sort of everything together there's a
strong mathematical motivation to look
for all those particles you know that
this symmetry implies but that I mean
how do you then make the argument to the
governments and the funding agencies
right because this is not a small
undertaking right I mean this is part of
the motivation for the Large Hadron
Collider as well as with the Higgs how
much does that machine did that machine
cost what was the cost of the LHC in the
end I mean it's it's hard to do you
remember them what's the final number of
the LHC it's you know it's billions of
dollars number two to quantify I mean
because in that number you have you know
like my salary and Joe's salary you know
I'm sure it's a very small fraction out
to 12 billion
but you know yeah it was but you know I
think that's the time that the LHC was
built was was a very unique time in
particle physics and it's exactly like
it's a unique time like we're at right
now so there's a great symmetry between
you know the start at the LHC and the
start of what's going to happen next
which was you know we had a tremendous
amount of evidence is the wrong word but
we had a tremendous amount of consensus
that there was going that we would
discover something at this energy this
energy is very unique to the standard
model so the energy at which the LHC can
probe let's say the energy of particles
at the LHC has is has enough to produce
is it's a very key energy to the theory
itself and so if you expected
supersymmetry to appear you would have
expected it to appear at the LHC energy
did you did you expect it in fact I'd
like to ask all three of you because
there's a lot of rewriting I find of
history post facto that happens and
we're just a small group of friends
intimate gathering here I mean how many
of you really would have argued and
thought that supersymmetry those other
particles that we saw briefly on the
right-hand side of the screen would be
found by now at the Large Hadron
Collider nema I mean what did you well I
I think and then look over yes or no
here just so I can like actually because
it's not just about supersymmetry yes
there is an intent only something will
we'll come to in a second there's a sort
of whole paradigm yes that goes around
the existence of the Higgs particle how
strange it is how bizarre would be to
have the Higgs is a lonely beast
accompanied by anything else that's
something even when we've seen roughly
this kind of phenomenon elsewhere in
physics before we've never seen
something like that for very good
theoretical reasons that perhaps will
become too so there's a whole sort of
paradigm built around what it would take
to see something like the Higgs particle
yeah and it's that whole pursue per
symmetry being the sort of best
developed a version of
and most concrete and and and and well
put-together version of that paradigm
and by the way it's not broadly the idea
of supersymmetry I mean the as it's been
said a couple of times supersymmetry is
just the very last thing nature can do
compatible with its grand principles
that we've not yet seen it do yeah and
but this is at the level of massless
particles right however there is mass in
nature and so so we have to go to high
enough energies where where we see all
the relevant particles in order to be
able to see the asymmetry from that
point of view supersymmetry could show
up you know anywhere it'll be relevant
for nature but there's a specific
problem associated with the Higgs
particle which we'll talk about more in
fact we can do it right now well yeah so
I think the all the drama about about
the Higgs and has to do with this with
this with this basic fact for all the
other elementary particles there's a
difference between them being massless
and being massive so for example if you
ask the question why is the photon
massless in this kind of in this analogy
you imagine that that that space is
filled with these violent quantum
mechanical fluctuations that are that
are going on everywhere while the photon
is zipping through this this kind of
medium why isn't it begging into all
this crap all the time and and picking
up some inertia just like the kind of
molasses picture that we going on all
over the place right you know there and
those quantum mechanical fluctuations
get more and more violent as you go to
shorter and shorter distances higher and
higher energies because of the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle so why
does the photon sort of impervious to
this go zipping through through through
space at the speed of light and the
reason is that two is not equal to three
okay because if the photon did have a
mass if it's somehow picked up a mass
with all these interactions that's not
you can't be a little bit massive it's
like being a little bit pregnant it's
not possible right those those extra
than the extra way that it can span has
got to come from somewhere and that's
the deep reason why particles that have
spin like the photon of the graviton
electron everything else there's a good
understanding for why they could be
massless in some approximation you've
got to do something to them to make the
masses here okay and and that's
something has everything to do with the
Higgs
that's the huge irony is that the thing
that solves the that gives us the
understanding for why all the other
things can be consistently massive and
there's a good reason why the mass of
all the elementary particles is pegged
to the scale associated with the Higgs
we don't understand why the Higgs itself
has them as kin has it mass or what
could be massless in some approximation
because the Higgs has no as spin zero
that's that's the strange thing about
it's a simplest elementary particle
we've ever seen it has no spin no charge
no kind of properties of any sort other
than having a mass and the difficulty is
that unlike photons for which massless
guy has been as two degrees of freedom
massive has three the Higgs has spin
zero and one is equal to one
there's no difference between the the
the number of ways namely none that a
massless or a massive Higgs particle can
have and therefore the Higgs is zipping
through this complicated quantum
mechanical vacuum there's absolutely no
reason why its interactions with all the
this virtual crap couldn't give it a
huge inertia and in fact if you do a
simple back of the envelope estimate for
where the Higgs should end up it would
be orders and orders and orders of
magnitude more massive than then naively
then then then we've actually seen it to
be so you need some explanation for why
the Higgs didn't pick up a lot of mass
going through all this flux exactly and
and and and it's really important to
stress this point it's not inconsistent
for it not to do so we can perfectly do
in fact we've done it right
Higgs did it before ever having thought
about any of these things but when you
think about it more deeply you would not
expect the Higgs to be right and in fact
nowhere else in physics where similar
phenomenon have shown up has something
like the Higgs ever been seen or ever
been been in something as simple as the
Higgs been the correct explanation so if
there is a mechanism if there's a reason
that we can we can understand that shows
up right around as has happened for 400
years in the history of physics where to
find him explanation for a phenomenon
that that takes place in some at some
scale you don't have to look at what's
going on you know 500 million times
smaller than that scale and that's a
sure opposite of right around the scale
of the mystery itself
if that mystery if the if the origin of
the mass of the Higgs was explainable in
that way that which has been the
trajectory we've been on for centuries
essentially the reductionist paradigm if
the reductionist paradigm that we've
been on for a century is it holds the
way it has before then we would have
expected to see something come along
with the Higgs it's like I've used this
analogy many people use this analogy the
sort of difficulty is like walking into
a room and seeing a pencil standing on
its tip and it's not inconsistent it's
perfectly allowed for a pencil to stand
on its tip and it's okay it's not
violating the laws of physics but if you
saw it you would probably try to find an
explanation right maybe it's hanging
from a string right there's a string
hang from the ceiling maybe you look
there's a little hand holding it up
right you need to find some mechanism to
explain it and it's that mechanism a
supersymmetry and the other ideas that
people have talked about for it for
decades were trying to look for a hand
holding it up so just to give a quick
summary so the idea is supersymmetry
provides an approach that at least on
paper allows the mass of the Higgs to
stay relatively small like ten or a
hundred times the mass of the proton but
not billions and trillions of time for
NASA it's very much related to what to
how we were just talking about what what
supersymmetry is about you see
supersymmetry relates particles a
different spin and and and if the
particles have a spin we have no
difficulty understanding their mass
that's just what we have to do so by
relating something that has no spin to
something that does you we get to
inherit the clean understanding we have
so all of this gives some confidence
even if you're not willing to say it
directly but give some confidence that
we thought that supersymmetry was going
to be found I mean Joe did you I mean
just to show frustrated yes is at least
in the simplest version of using
supersymmetry to do this job you can
actually deal calculation that says the
Higgs boson can't be heavier than a
certain amount and that amount was
calculations actually done by my
colleague Marcela Karina who you saw in
the clip there it and that the answer
was a hundred and thirty in these units
that we've been using so when we found
the Higgs at 125 in those units it's
like okay the supersymmetry must be
right but it's right on the corner right
but it's been a really big corner so far
so as we turn the corner we have found
what happens on nothing we find right I
mean certainly from the experimental
community it was a pretty heavy romance
with supersymmetry much more be honest
because I mean from the experimental
perspective it was the experimentalist
dream I mean it was gonna be one new
particle for every particle that we
already have right I mean I remember
when I showed up at the LHC and I was
it's just very young postdoc at that
time and I was working on the trigger
system so the system that you know helps
us keep events versus rejecting them and
I remember you know senior physicists
coming up to me and saying like you know
you got to be really careful
supersymmetry is gonna is gonna overload
the trigger and I remember thinking
myself like yeah I'm happy with that
problem
you know like I'm okay with that but
that was kind of the feeling was that
that that you know that this age of
discovery was it was gonna be this age
of discovery again and I think that we
you know I agree with you that I think
many people you know there were many
problems with supersymmetry you know
that were but we didn't want to hear it
at the time but even it's not just
experimentalist of course I mean I
haven't done a calculation of it but a
significant fraction of every single
paper I've ever written has
supersymmetry at its core the assumption
that these ideas deep theoretical idea
it's a very deep theoretical
mathematical idea which is driven even
mathematical discovery not even just
just discoveries or non discoveries in
physics but the bottom line is here we
are sitting in 2019 we built this
massive machine in Geneva it found the
one thing that we were really certain
about the Higgs particle and it has not
found the other particles that we
thought would come along for the party
because they're so as you've articulated
directly related to the Higgs as well as
the record added to this deep idea of
symmetry so the question is what do we
do from here and we can continue to
follow our mathematics as we will do but
in the end of the day we're going to
need data and we have to convince people
to build new machine so can you give us
a sense of where we are on the frontier
of building new machines that will have
higher energy be able to probe yet other
domains and perhaps maybe these
supersymmetric particles are there
they're just heavier so what's going on
and that's in that space so there is
let's say a roadmap right now but I
think there's no there's no money yet
let's say in part of this and there's
two projects that let's say if money was
not a question what would we do in
particle physics well we would build two
things we'd build two new accelerators
one of which is would be a linear
collider Japan has expressed a lot of
interest in building such a Collider and
hosting such a Collider let's say and
this would be where you instead of
colliding electrons and protons you
would be colliding sorry instead of
writing colliding protons you'd be
colliding electrons and positrons it's a
it's a linear machine so you've got
extremely long and you basically collide
them into each other and why is it good
idea to do those particle as opposed to
proton so they vanish'd electrons is
that their point like and therefore
they're just clean the problem is when
you take two protons and you smash them
together you you what you're doing
actually is you're smashing two quarks
from inside those protons but the actual
how much energy those quarks have inside
the proton is very difficult to model
and then on top of that you've got the
rest of the proton that breaks up and it
just leaves if you look at pictures I
think we have some pictures of what a
collision looks like for example and in
one of the detectors you'll see there's
just huge amounts of particles coming
out and we see here like what you see
here so here in this event you actually
only have two particles that you're
actually interested in this would be
kind of what you kind of see with these
these big red blue clusters of energy
those would be the two particles that
you're interested in and music tracks
and these are all green is all tracks of
particles and so forth and so on and
most of this is just crap from from
that's actually that is the 10th week we
use that a lot of publications yes
yeah so you know that's just the crap
that comes in in an electron positron
collision everything's clean you don't
have this breakup of the of the and you
know exactly what the electron energy is
so from a precision measurement
perspective its superior absolutely
superior however if you want to really
go high energies then you've got to go
protons protons are what gives you your
power in terms of the energy aspect and
so in addition to a linear collider in
in the ideal world it's what we would
have so we'd have an ideal Clutton
linear collider to really measure her
top and Higgs extremely precisely and
then in the ideal world we would have
another Hadron Collider which was you
know the well the next generation the
FCC future circular Collider or there's
a where might that be and that would be
at CERN this is a picture of what it
looks like it's actually very it would
be a hundred kilometer ring and we just
pointed out it's clear up there but
disappointed the LHC is a smaller ring
here and what's actually interesting
about the circular collider is that God
apparently put mountain ranges exactly
perfectly such that you could build such
a tunnel I'd would have to go underneath
Lake Geneva and it would it would just
pass right before the Alps pass right
before the celeb coming back so it's
just perfect going under the lake is
actually not a problem everyone will
always ask about going underneath the
lake but you know the thing about a lake
because I always worried that it's gonna
be a leak you know think about a lake is
that there's never a leak in the lake
because if there was you wouldn't have a
lake so going underneath underneath the
lake is no problem but but it is a
problem in the sense that you do have
mountains and mountains lead to a lot of
water drain so the energy scale of that
machine so this would be hundred
kilometres and I thought yes a hundred
TV machine it's roughly not quite but
maybe eight times eight times what we
have now the LHC here was 14 and then
you had the temperature on which was
which was lower and so this would be
your real discovery machine right which
would be go out to to 100 TeV and you
would you know be head again it would be
proton proton Joe let me ask you a
question just so we have those numbers
up there so NEMA was
describing how the energy scale that the
Higgs was at and supersymmetry in its
most conventional formulation it all
seemed to come together it was all
happening at the right energy scale now
when we go say from 14,000 times you
know the mass of the or you know 14 TeV
to a hundred even factor of eight in
there is their theoretical motivation at
that particular slice of energy space is
going to really hold something new or we
just simply saying let's go bigger
because we haven't found anything yet
well of course it's a combination of
those things because there's never a
guarantee that any particular Collider
is going to discover anything we didn't
we didn't know that the LHC would
discover anything so you're always
making a gamble but there is motivation
that if the idea is that we've been
talking about have any validity at all
if they're not totally wrong yeah that
that may be what we were we're missing
is we didn't quite have a powerful
enough tool to see them and and you know
what's the probability of that nobody
knows this is why it's discovery science
you're always taking risks and Neema can
a few broad points I mean first of all
we go to the frontier because it's the
frontier so that's that's the
zeroth-order thing and but I think it if
if you think that that particle physics
is about discovering new particles and
so you're only going to build a machine
if you know for a fact you're gonna
discover a new particle and you have
some idea where it's going to be and so
on then this is a perfectly good time to
take your ball and go home and do
something else with your life okay
because we have absolutely no guarantee
I cannot stress this enough absolutely
zero guarantee that that a new machine
is going to produce a new particle there
are some indications for a new
phenomenon that would happen at scales
you know having to do with gravity and
things like that or does in orders of
magnitude removed from where we are but
we had lots of theoretical arguments
that something should happen right
around the scale of the LHC we haven't
seen them and they were in any case
there were circumstantial indirect
arguments anyway so we there's no
guarantee that there are new particles
however
this entire and that's why I alluded to
this earlier when we were talking about
the building blocks of matter picture of
the world it's maybe a little a little
funny that's certainly not what drew me
personally yeah into fundamental physics
I don't care that much about the
building blocks of matter it's a lot
like chemistry I sucked very badly at
chemistry in school and I don't care
that much about the building blocks of
matter I care about the structure of the
fundamental laws of nature yeah and
we've learned that that that the that
the elementary particles are the are the
letters of the novel that we're
interested in the novel we're interested
in the in the structure of the laws of
nature and they're what we really care
about a new new principles new
phenomenon and from that point of view
the Higgs is damn new it's very strange
we've never seen anything like it before
and so I think the main to me and I
think the most people proposing these
future machines the main thing we'll
learn for sure from doing these new
experiments are fundamental facts about
the Higgs we've never seen an elementary
particle like the Higgs before we have
to put it under a very powerful
microscope more powerful microscope than
we have at the LHC and that the main
drama about the Higgs is whether it
really looks elementary or not whether
it really looks point-like or not from
the LHC we're gonna get a pretty fuzzy
picture of how point like the the Higgs
looks you really have to put it under
and and in fact it's fuzzy enough that
we've seen roughly analogous things to
it elsewhere in particle physics most of
you probably haven't heard of this
particle there's a very important
particle known as the PI on that also at
first blush looks like it might might be
kind of an elementary particle of spin
zero but very quickly you see that when
you just put it under a magnifying glass
with magnification five you see that
it's actually made up at a little quarks
held together with glue on so whew all
the theoretical drama that could have
been there with the Higgs was actually
not there with the PI on well that's the
resolution we're gonna get on the Higgs
from the LHC more or less that same kind
of factor of five resolution that we had
with the PI on we need another factor of
10 on top of that to know if it's
something really really new if it's
point-like as we expect actually in the
standard model or if it has some sub sub
sub structure and so there there are two
kinds of experiments that we can do one
is to see whether it looks quite like
two other things like if you literally
want to see that it looks point like you
want to see what happens when a photon
bounces in into the Higgs of course the
Higgs doesn't actually live very long so
um analogous so if proven dueño hates
decays the two photons or into other
things and then you see whether that
interaction of the Higgs with other
stuff is compatible the higest looking
point like that's what these so-called
Higgs factories will do the linear
machine that Monica was talking about is
is a great machine to do this it would
produce millions of Higgs particles in a
very clean environment actually these
circular 100-kilometer machines could do
exactly the same thing if you collide in
them the same electrons and positrons so
that's one of the great things about
these circular machines is that they
could do double duty you could first
collide electrons and positrons produce
millions of Higgs particles and and see
whether it looks point like to external
probes like photons and the other things
that it could run into and then
ultimately if you go to the hundred T V
colliders if you collide protons and
exactly the same machine you can ask and
settle the question whether the Higgs
looks point like ultimately to itself
and that's kind of a sort of a
fascinating thing the very simplest
interaction elementary particles can
enjoy is with three of them meet at a
common point in space and time and it
turns out no other elementary parts
Engle elementary particle actually has
this interaction every other thing that
we know there's something that changes
some some property changes the Higgs is
the only elementary particle that can
have as its dominant interaction this
interaction with itself and therefore by
looking for this interaction not only
for the first time seeing the sort of
simplest possible interaction in nature
but you're checking to see whether the
Higgs actually looks point like even to
itself the LHC is not even going to tell
us with confidence whether this
interaction even exists but the hundred
T V Collider will produce billions of
Higgs particles and by doing that will
not only tell us if exist but I'll
measure it to a few percent accuracy so
I've just told you what I think of and I
think most most of the people pushing
for this next generation of accelerator
they're not promising oh we just barely
met supersymmetry might be right around
the corner that might be true okay but
that's not the logic of the argument at
this point the logic
the argument has to do with the
fundamental kind of paradigm shifting
paradigm challenging nature of the Higgs
itself and the fact that theorists are
confused 40 years of ideas for what
might be associated with the LHC but
what the Higgs have certainly not been
have not been amply confirmed at the LHC
not even close when theorists are
confused you need more experiments and
you need to do experiments on the thing
that's confusing the Higgs is the thing
that's confusing so we have to put it
under a very powerful magnifying glass
very well said
now when when we look at the big
principles so one thing to do is to
smash harder to magnify greater to try
to see fundamental structure that we may
have missed and so on but in terms of
overarching theoretical paradigms that
will guide us forward so supersymmetry
is not ruled out it could still be part
of the story but what I mean maybe just
go down the line a little Joe what would
you say I mean obviously there are
things that people have string theory
people which have supersymmetry
there are other things like Technicolor
that people have spoken about do you
feel that we've got the guiding
theoretical structure to really give us
a clear path going forward as to what we
should be looking for I think we're in
one of those periods of physics history
where we really need guidance from data
it's we have ideas some of them I'm sure
are good ideas but we need we need more
we need nature to tell us more about
what's really going on and this has
actually been more the typical situation
in the history of physics then then you
know having confidence and you know
Dirac was as I said was the lucky guy
where he had the idea and then the
experiment came right along that this is
the typical situation where we're we
have some ideas part of it's probably
right part of it's probably wrong
there's probably something missing and
we need data to sort that out and that's
what these more powerful instruments are
really for there's a nightmare scenario
that you described for the the LHC
imagined some next machine is built
what would your nightmare scenario be
there well actually I think that you
know coming back having looked back now
nine years later
and you know lots of data later we
didn't have any data at that time right
so we were sort of in a you know I
definitely have also sort of had let's
say eye opening experience out of the
whole thing and I think that you know
basically supersymmetry basically did us
experimentally a disservice let's say
because because it sort of set this
expectation that I think that you know
that that the LHC was going to be the
discovery machine in the sense of
discovering particles and the LHC has
been a discovery machine and I think
that you know because we have learned a
tremendous amount the LHC has given us
many many precision measurements of the
standard model the detectors that we
have are beautiful they're stunning the
amount of precision we can get out of
these detectors is amazing it's really
been an absolute success in terms of
what we've been able to measure and as I
said we discovered the Higgs in 2012 no
one expected that our detectors would be
at that precision at that time we've
been making measurements that we never
thought I mean Nima says we won't be
able to measure the the Higgs self
coupling but you know already we're
doing studies that show that we could
maybe start to access it so forth so on
so I think that we have made tremendous
progress in technology we've made
tremendous progress in precision
measurements of the standard model and I
think this idea that that you know
physics particle physics was about new
particles was really a disservice to us
and in this comment that I made you know
ten years ago saying would be Higgs and
Hicks only it's the worst case scenario
is it's absolutely a reflection of that
time I think is a reflection of how how
we were viewing progress at that time
and I think we've all there has been a
big emotional shift in in physics in the
sense that exactly as joe says that we
need the data we need to know the
standard model better before we can
really say you know let's go in
direction a B or C and that we're really
despite its successes despite how much
we know about the standard model we've
all discovered that it's not enough yeah
and and these next-generation machines
are exactly that so in that sense my
worst-case scenario would be pretty much
a
you know a fire in the cavern I think so
you know
yeah real a real disaster
I think we're we're at a moment the the
the most important thing is that we've
seen this phenomenon that we've never
seen before and so I think it's it's
it's it's very funny that in a sense
seeing the Higgs and nothing else so far
is by far the most shocking thing that
could have happened that could have come
out of the LHC experiment it's the
biggest challenge to theorists it shakes
the conceptual grounds under us more
than had we seen these things that we
expecting for a decades it's actually
funny when I was a grad student there
was such an expectation that something
like supersymmetry was right and that
was an idea that people came up with 70s
and 80s and the job of my generation was
to clean up the details and figure out
how precisely it broke and worked out
and so on and that's definitely not how
it's worked out in fact the challenge
just got greater got much greater the
the stakes went became more more
structural rather than about this or
that detail or this or that additional
particle like that I can't stress that
enough I think that that the last time a
whole community of theoretical
physicists have been so perplexed by
something and have had experimental
results not aligned with what they
expected was when we expected the
universe was filled with an ether and
the absence of the ether a null
experiment was the was the harbinger of
the revolutions to come this idea that a
whole generation of particle physicists
grew up with that what glory looks like
was the 1960s with a particle every week
it's true was a wonderful period but
that was not you know in 200 years this
will not be the the great thing about
the 20th century the great thing about
the 20th century was the relativity and
quantum mechanics and there's lots and
lots of very important details after
that but these very revolutionary kind
of conceptually earth-shaking
discoveries don't have that character
yeah they had their they have their
surprising they involve things that that
that that happened that that you
wouldn't expect and so I think we're a
nut we're in another one of those
periods today and the heat is not the
only
you know you've talked in these programs
eloquently or many many years there have
been there's one other very important
experimental shock to the system in the
late 1990s when we discovered the
universe is accelerating okay and these
are two different ratings the expansion
of the universe is actually accelerating
and rate these are two very
theoretically from a theoretical money
but they're very closely related shocks
our astronomer colleagues want to go
measure the heck out of the expansion of
the universe and our part of his
experiments we're gonna go measure the
heck out of the Higgs and these are
actually very closely related conceptual
mysteries I believe I'm certainly not
the only one but I definitely believe
that we're at another one of these
periods that comes around every 100
years or so where the where the issues
at stake go up one order of magnitude in
sort of structural significance and in
many ways the Higgs is the most
important experimental actor in the
story because it can be put under
scrutiny have okay can be put under a
powerful microscope be put under put
under scrutiny yeah so all this talk of
disappointment and nightmares and so on
is I think kind of crazy you know just
because you're in these conversations I
need to sort of play devil's advocate
but in you know 2010 or 2011 I wrote an
op-ed for The Times in which I wrote
about finding nothing unexpected at the
LHC as being one of the most potent
possibilities that could emerge as
opposed to this standard frame of mind
that you're articulating which is
particle find more products and more
particles so I fully agree but I want to
finish on one point related to the the
note that you just made about accelerate
expansion cosmological ideas I just want
to finish on a cosmological question so
Joe you have written about a curious
feature of the Higgs phenomenon which is
that you know in the very early universe
at least in many conventional
formulations the Higgs field wasn't
actually permeating space then it was
only a little bit later on that the
universe kind of went through a
transition yes where the Higgs then
permeated everything so it went through
a phase transition a change of a very
radical sort the particular
ask for the Higgs field that we found
suggest at least the possibility that we
could be facing another such
cosmological change in our future so
since that's a very bright note to
conclude on maybe you can describe what
it is that we're referring to at the end
of the universe yes exactly so as you
said that we believe the cosmic molasses
wasn't always there it actually turned
the Higgs turned itself on if you like
at some point in the early universe
that's the phase transition talking
about and so you can ask the question
well is is the cosmic molasses just
going to stay the way it is forever or
at some point will something else happen
that involves this and there is a
calculation that you can do at least
with with those standard model equations
that we have now that we know the Higgs
boson and its mass we have all the all
the numbers that you need to do a
calculation like that and some of our
colleagues have done these calculations
very carefully and and interestingly
enough we seem to be right on the
borderline of the universe that will
eventually want to change into something
else it seems that our universe is
slightly unstable - at some point a
little bubble of something else where
the Higgs is doing something else will
appear siyou or a different value and
once that bubble appears it will expand
at basically the speed of light and
eventually it'll get to get to us and
I'm gonna get to us way and that'll be
the end of us though it'll be a
different universe but we won't be there
anymore now the chant even if this
calculation is right you would expect
this to happen incredibly far in the
future so it's not it's not I think it's
more it's on the order of ten to the
hundred years from now so even in the
billions of billions of years it's it's
a very long time so you shouldn't
actually worry about this I have got an
email from people saying I can't sleep
at night because I'm worried about this
I always reply you you know you have
many other things you should be worried
about but this is not one of them but
two two particle physicists this is an
incredibly profound thing it's a
question of what is is the Higgs really
forever and if it's not forever what
what does that mean and one possibility
is again this leads back to ideas like
supersymmetry if you think yeah that
nature should make stable universes then
you need some some ingredient
that we need to add and what is that
ingredient right know what one thing we
presume you could also write back to
people with that concern is since this
bubble of sort of a new phase is
expanding at the speed of light by the
time you see it it's upon you yeah you
don't have to have to worry you won't
see it coming you'll just be looks like
inside this bubble you know because
what's going on is the heat gets a lot
bigger inside the bubble so that means
that every particle in your body that
has a mass gets way more massive inside
so anything massive go splat well right
you know it's stars you me everything
would go splat on this except light
light goes sailing right through so if
you if you or some progeny of yours
manages to make it inside the bubble and
run at the speed of light to sort of
keep up with the width of all the bubble
it's literally like being on the inside
of a car with flies on the windscreen
right you know the whole rest of the
universe is just going splat on this
bubble as it as it goes goes through you
so it's a very cheering thought indeed a
couple minutes to go and I just want to
give you all a chance for sort of a
final word compared to where we were say
10 15 years ago are you do you think
that we've gotten to a more exciting
place do you think that we've kind of
gone through the doldrums I mean what
would you characterize the state of
particle physics to be today maybe just
right I always remember when I was
having a really frustrating time as a
graduate student a senior graduate
student and my group saying if it was
easy it would have been done already and
I think that pretty much really
describes where particle physics is
right now there's absolutely nothing
about particle physics that's easy and I
think I don't know a single particle
physicist who went into this field
because they wanted it to be easier so
in that sense I'm personally excited
about the challenge it's going to be
hard as hell to build experiments for
these new coal
lighters bring it on I'm ready and I'm
ready to take on the measure the Higgs
as well as we can
all right NEMA well III tell him my grad
student said if I could go back in time
and control when I'd be born I would
wish that I was entering grad school
today
III really think I really think this is
from my point of view it's the most
exciting time in fundamental physics in
certainly in 50 or 60 years maybe going
back to the to the time when relativity
and quantum mechanics ended up coming
into existence and um and it might sound
crazy I mean you know that there again
there's there are other people were
wandering around they're sort of
depressed we have seen the Higgs and
nothing else so who's right you know I
might just on drugs or they aren't drug
what and and I think it really depends
on why you got into this business if if
what really drives you is is trying to
understand something deeply conceptually
new about the world that kind of
opportunity does not come along every
ten or 20 years or so most people don't
get to experience that and I think we're
now at the point after slogging through
all kinds of easier questions where you
know in science you're you're motivated
by gigantic questions but you have to
work on the next question you have no
choice but to work on the next question
well we're finally at the point where
the next questions are these gigantic
ones are these sort of existential ones
what space and time what's the origin
and the fate of our enormous universe
why can there be large macroscopic
structures when there are the enormous
quantum mechanical fluctuations that
seem to want to destroy them and so on
these questions even seem to be
interrelated to each other in some way
potentially and our generation of people
are the generation we will get to work
on these questions responsibly it's
meaningful for us to work on them
because there isn't like ten other
questions in between us and then and so
I'd like to say it's like you want to
climb Mount Everest first you have to
you know get in a plane go to Kathmandu
find Sherpas foothills all kinds of
stuff finally we get the base camp right
and you get to see the beast for the
first time then decide what you want to
do you want to wait for oxygens be
oxygen masks be invented otherwise it
might go up and die or do you start
trying to climb in some way that's where
we are I think we're at a point where
finally staring at these most
profound questions about the nature of
reality and we get to work on them and
we get to work on them as theorists and
we get to you know take on the mighty
sort of generation scale challenge of
attacking some of these questions as
experimentalist so I think it's a
fantastic time to be a a physicist but
you have to have the understanding that
that you have to be in this business for
the long haul and and you may well go
3040 years you may easily die without
having made substantial progress on the
questions that you are interested in but
that's what you have to do if you're
interested in this kind of thing
Joe yeah along the same line speaking to
somebody that's at a big national lab if
you look at what our young people are
doing now at these labs they're
motivated by the big scientific
challenges they're trying to develop new
technologies to build us these better
microscopes that we know we're going to
need to make these discoveries and and
so those those technology challenges are
equally fascinating and interesting as
these scientific questions that are
motivating them and I think that sort of
cycle of this big science questions
motivating us to push the technology so
that we can do the experiments that we
haven't been able to do yet I think
that's a very virtuous cycle and it's
one of the things that that we do for
society that that's really important
grateful it's been a fascinating
conversation please join me in thanking
everybody
[Applause]
you
[Music]